damond is likely the most conservative
investor on shark tank but usually it's
not because he's afraid of capital loss
but because of his investment philosophy
you see all the sharks are there for
various reasons mark and robert like to
invest in businesses that excite them
kevin likes to invest in businesses that
carry low capital risk
lori likes to invest in ideas she can
blow up on tv and the barbara invests in
entrepreneurs that she believes in but
today min doesn't really care about any
of this he's not there to make money or
gain popularity his primary goal is to
help entrepreneurs who really truly need
it
tracy
i'll give you fifty thousand for thirty
percent come on of course
well look at that
there are so many times that he's turned
down super lucrative deals because he
doesn't feel that the entrepreneur needs
his help i think this makes de mende the
most wholesome investor on the show and
given his rough background it makes
sense that he wants to help those in a
similar situation
you know i started doing a lot of little
odd jobs when i was growing up you know
i would uh rake leaves in the fall i
would shovel snow in the winter this
wholesome investment strategy has
rewarded him quite handsomely given that
he was the one to invest in shark tank's
most successful business so here's how
demand went from the ghettos to shark
tank and became shark tank's most
empathetic investor
taking a look back damond was born on
february 23 1969 in brooklyn new york
initially his life wasn't that bad
financially given that he was an only
child and his dad made enough money to
make ends meet but by the time damond
was 10 years old his parents would get a
divorce and the daymen would be raised
by a single mother to make things worse
damon's mother was a homemaker and it
was extremely difficult for her to find
a job the family quickly sank into
poverty and ended up in the halls region
of queens this region is known as a
low-income african-american neighborhood
also known as a ghetto so to help out
his mom through the situation they meant
to begin working odd jobs at the age of
10. this included handing out flyers for
two dollars an hour and to becoming an
electrician apprentice he also shoveled
snow for neighbors and sold pencils
moving into high school they aiming to
join a program that allowed him to
attend school on an alternating weekly
basis this allowed him to hold a
full-time job as a waiter at red lobster
and run a small commuter van service on
the side
damon says that this program is what
really ignited his entrepreneurial
spirit
anyway moving on to college damond
really had no intention of attending
college first of all he was dyslexic
which made traditional academics quite
difficult and secondly he didn't have
four years to go sit in a classroom he
was already busting his butt to make
ends meet and quitting his job would
make it extremely difficult on his
mother so he decided to not attend
college and continued on with his waiter
job after high school damon wasn't
satisfied with just working this job for
the rest of his life though he knew that
he wanted to create some sort of
business but he didn't know what exactly
it would be about this would all change
however when he came across some
overpriced wolsky hats on the market
damond was convinced that he could
produce the hats for significantly
cheaper so he bought some low-cost
fabrics learned how to sew from his
mother and to begin knitting wool hats
he was able to produce 80 hats and he
went around the neighborhood and sold
them for ten dollars a piece he made a
solid 800 revenue from the venture but
for daymond selling these hats meant
much more than just making money you'll
see it during his teenage years damon
was a massive fan of hip-hop and rap he
aspired to be like his favorite artists
but usually he couldn't even afford the
clothes they wore by selling affordable
clothes rooted in hip-hop damon felt
that he could appeal to his younger self
and give modern kids what he never had
and with that damon founded for us bias
or fubu in 1992
damond barely had any money himself but
his mother would pull through and risk
it all for damond she mortgaged her
house and lent him 100 000 to start up
their business
mistakes couldn't have been higher but
this was damon's one shot at a better
life and there was no way he was going
to give that up
from the very beginning damien knew that
the key to growing a large clothing
brand was exposure but he decided to
start small and keep things simple
daemon continued to produce the wool
hats that had already sold well and he
continued working as a waiter in the
meantime he started experimenting with
sewing screen printed t-shirts
as the hat business grew damond hired
two of his childhood friends to start
selling t-shirts around the neighborhood
this worked out decently well at the
beginning but selling clothes
door-to-door clearly wasn't a very good
sales channel long term so damon started
leveraging consignments a consignment is
simply an agreement with a store or
vendor to sell your products for a set
commission or fee damond was able to
score a couple of consignment deals with
vendors in the northeast and with that
they many could start focusing on
actually building a brand damond and his
friends started selling the fubu logo
into hockey jerseys sweatshirts and
t-shirts and they lent out this clothing
to up-and-coming rappers to use in their
music videos within just two years
demand was able to secure product
placement within 30 music videos which
gave fubu quite a bit of exposure people
watching these music videos thought that
fubu was a decently sized small brand
but really it was just damond and a
couple of his friends and this became
painfully apparent when fubu started to
receive their first big orders in the
early 1990s damon traveled to las vegas
to showcase fubu at a fashion trade show
called magic this was definitely a
worthwhile trip given that he received
three hundred thousand dollars worth of
orders and an offer to be sold at select
macy's outlets damon had played took the
orders but only he knew that it was
going to be a massive struggle to
produce that many clothes as soon as he
returned home damon applied for loans at
every bank he could think of but he was
rejected from all 27 banks he applied to
so in a last-ditch effort damon used the
last of his money to put out an
advertisement in the new york times
looking for a manufacturing partner and
luckily for day mended samsung textiles
responded to the ad and helped fubu
complete their first mega order around
the same time daemon's hip-hop partners
including will smith beyonce and alcoj
were starting to get some notoriety ella
cool j and daymind were actually
childhood friends and the damien was
able to convince cool jay to wear a fubu
hat in a gap commercial cool jay didn't
just stop right there either he was
hired to rap in the commercial and he
snuck in the phrase for us by us in the
rap
c-a-p gritty ready to go for us brothers
on the low g that's forgetting honestly
i'm not sure how gap let this one slip
by but it worked out great for fubu as
their hip-hop partners evolved into
full-fledged celebrities fubu
transitioned from being a small home
business to a national brand in 1998
fubu pulled in 350 million dollars in
sales but damond was just getting
started
fubu was doing better than ever before
damien knew that hip-hop theme was
fickle and that it could disappear just
as fast as it appeared so damon de
cleverly started to diversify as soon as
possible in the late 1990s and early
2000s fubu put hip-hop promotions on the
back burner and started to reinvest
their profits into building an
international audience they primarily
targeted saudi arabia china korea japan
and south africa daemon didn't just
limit the company to streetwear clothing
either in 2000 he launched football
entertainment also known as fubu records
as the name suggests this subsidiary was
focused on producing and releasing music
albums one of their first deals was with
universal records which ended up
generating millions in revenue moving
forward in 2002 daemon embraced internet
with the launch of ytg.com which sold
their various products online all of
these efforts gave fubu a pretty solid
safety net but damon didn't just want to
rely on fubu either so he also started
ventures outside fubu for example daemon
leverages new found fame to start
selling books so far demind has
published four books called display of
power the brand within the power of
broke and rise and grind these
publications have won them the titles of
new york times and wall street journal
best-selling author
aside from publishing books daemon has
also become a public speaker and he
charges 50 to 75 000 per speech demand
has also partnered with several brands
including pitbull miss universe shopify
and most recently audible it's a good
thing damon diversified so heavily as
fubu sales did indeed start dropping
just like he expected from their peak of
350 million dollars in 1998 fubu
declined to 200 million by 1999 and
they've stabilized around there ever
since damon doesn't seem to mind too
much though he knew the drop was coming
and prepared as much as he could also he
had already made more money than he ever
wanted and now he wanted to focus his
efforts on giving back
damon isn't interested in making the
rich richer or even the middle class
richer his primary goal is to help the
poor break out of the poverty cycle he
knows firsthand how impossible it was to
secure a loan and with shark tank
diamond has prioritized giving
opportunity just like samsung textiles
gave him an opportunity one of the best
examples of this was with most bows in
season five of shark tank a young
entrepreneur named moziah pitched his
bow tie making business he asked for a
modest fifty thousand dollars for twenty
percent stake in his business but
instead of offering him the money damon
offered to mentor him for free since
then dementia has helped mozaya secure a
manufacturing partner get into neiman
marcus and even get a seven-figure
licensing deal with the nba they meant
it literally made this kid into a
millionaire for free i don't think it
gets more wholesome than that another
wholesome damage deal was bombas bombas
is a sock company that focuses on
donating socks to homeless shelters the
founders david and randy started the
company after finding out that the most
needed item at homeless shelters was
socks and for every item you purchased
from bombas they donate an item to
homeless organizations it looks like
this message has really resonated with
customers as bombbus is not only damon's
most successful investment but the most
successful investment in shark tank
history grossing a total of 225 million
dollars in lifetime sales shark tank
isn't the only way day many gives back
either in 2015 he co-founded damon
john's success formula which teaches
entrepreneurs how to start and grow
their business and that's emir he was
appointed by president obama to be an
ambassador for underserved entrepreneurs
considering all of this i don't think
there's any doubt that damon is the most
selfless shark on the show
as for damon today he's doing better
than ever before fubu crossed six
billion dollars in annual sales back in
2016 and they're likely in the seven to
eight billion dollar range today if not
even higher
in terms of shark tank investments
daemon has completed 61 deals on air
which comes out to a total of 8.5
million invested considering this i
don't think you'd be too surprised here
that net worth is estimated to be around
350 million dollars unfortunately though
his personal life isn't progressing
nearly as smoothly in april of 2017
damian was diagnosed with stage 2
thyroid cancer he did undergo surgery
and get the cancerous node removed but
it's definitely not something to take
lightly hopefully the cancer never
returns though as the amount is not only
relatively young at 52 but he's a
phenomenal community oriented person and
he would be a massive loss for everybody
do you guys think damon is the best
shark comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that the
other sharks should take a couple of
notes from
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you